thank you very much uh lebroods for
giving me the
opportunity to present today about the
landscape of pharmacogenetical resources
i will focus on the pharmacogene
variation consortium
what we offer to the pharma coach
genomic
community and how we fit into
other resources and what we provide to
the
community research and translational
wise to uh further research and
uh implementation so before i
really get to from bar um i want to take
you back about
20 years to the year 1996.
this is where cytochrome p450
nomenclature was first published
and back then a group of experts got
together as they realized that variation
in pharmacogenes
is really a challenge um as
many methods experienced a revolution
and resequencing and gene
characterization
became really what labs were doing
much more easily and fast
more and more variants were discovered
and so the need to really find a common
language
to catalog these variants in a way we
could
all understand was really central
and so they encouraged scientists to
speak
the same language worldwide and came up
with
a nomenclature that became known as the
star nomenclature and so
um because these variants
were becoming more and more and in 1996
the first paper was published on
cytogram p452d6
and then five years later around 2000 or
2001 this nomenclature was
expanded to other cytogram p450s
and it was shown in the last paper
that kept track of these really in paper
form
they had a list of over 25 pages or so
of variants that that was not
feasible and sustainable over time but
then there was this internet which
uh of course uh provided the perfect
platform
to do so and this is when the cytogram
p450 nomenclature page
uh made its debut on the internet
and that was back in 2002
and that was under the leadership of
magnus engelmann sunburg
at the karolinska institute and so as
you can see here up to the left this
is the catalog of cytochrome p450 jeans
for which this
website kept track of and built this
nomenclature over the next
15 years and the um
pharmacogenetics and genomics community
has become reliant on this centrally
run database people submitted their uh
novel variants and it was really the go
to a page to inform yourself
and up all the resources of
pharmacogenetic
variation
but then in 2017
is when uh magnus ingamon sunberg
decided to move on to other research
endeavors
he was looking for a new generation of
experts
to take this over and actually
really lift this nomenclature page
up into a new century and into a new
database
and this is where myself and others are
other experts from the farm gkp
and other experts in the field again
came together and stuck our heads
together to see
how can we take that and build a better
database
to serve future generations in
pharmacogenetics
without what magnus has built before
and this is where um the human allele
nomenclature database
was transitioned into the farm bar
database or to the pharmacogene
variation consortium
and as you can see here on this slide we
work closely together with the
farm gkp another uh well-known
database for pharmacogenetic variation
before i go our further ahead i also
really want to give you
a quick run-through of what the
pharmacogenes
star nomenclature are really is so what
you see here on the left
is how it's written so you first have
the species
so um this is for humans you have the
super family
g name which is cyp or sip for short
you have the family which in this
example is two
subfamily which is d then you have the
iso form which is six
and then the allele the different
variance
is what is that star number so you can
see here
in this example it's the star five so
there are
at least five uh different uh variants
and these are all different topotypes
for this gene
so for 2d6 we are now up to 141
so this is an example of a highly
variant of
entirely polymorphic pharmacogene
and so farmvar holds up mostly
cytogram p450 so this is what we have
inherited from the original
nomenclature site but we are also
expanding to
other clinically actionable
pharmacogenes
and so far we have introduced a
nomenclature for nut 15
and more recently on dpyt and as i will
show you we are also
um starting to work on our first
transporter slc-01b1 later this fall
now there are also other web-based sites
for other genes
namely tpnt utts
nats and l aldh nomenclature
but yet for others there are only
recommendations there is no
standard nomenclature no centralized
site
that keeps track of everything and so
the star nomenclature for these
might be a very uh loosely applied and
used in the literature
which can be really difficult um to
follow up
and keep track of so why are haplotypes
are important in the first place so this
is what i
want to show and demonstrate here on two
examples
for cytogram p450 tuesday 19.
so in the top half of
this line you see an example of a
diplotype we call star 1 star 2
and star 1 star 35 and so you see
two snips here in red these are both
snips that confer
alternative splicing and so on the
allele we call star 2
both snips are present in the star 35
however
only one is of these is
present now the snip that is typically
tested for is c
681 now you can easily see
should this snip not be tested
well then you are not identifying the
star 35
and what that means is that this allele
would
default to a star one and then your
genotype would not be accurate
and the phenotype you predict from this
subject would not be correct either
so knowing which snips are together and
can
occur on the same haplotype is rather
important because that might
direct you to what is important
for testing and it also allows you
to gain more understanding of
these snips that that are tested in an
outside or by
a company to see what this test
menu might miss and which alleles you
might
not see and which might default to a
star one
now in the bottom example we have
an allele that is called a star four
and here um there is an eight to a g
snip and that affects the translation
star
codon now this snip is often accompanied
by the snip
shown in blue which is in the upstream
region
and if that snip occurs on its own it
actually increases expression levels now
these two snips can occur
in cis then it makes a star
four of zero zero one subtype
or they can occur in trends
and while either diplotype is translated
into the same phenotype in this
example you could easily imagine that if
that more rare
snip in red that defines the style 4
allele is not
tested you would really end up with the
wrong genotype because
that star 4 is a no function allele
while the snip shown in blue leads to
increased
expression and is therefore um
signifying an increased um
activity allele so i hope these two
examples um
really exemplify how important it is to
know which
snips occur together and what the
functional consequence
is so this here is the
pharmacogene variation consortium
lending site
and if you go to the tab uh
jeans you will get to achieve a list
from which you can uh pick the gene of
interest
and on the next slide i'm showing the
gene page for cytogram p450
at 2d6 and on this
side or each gene page you find
really a series of important information
and features some of which i have
highlighted here with the
yellow arrows so one i really want to
emphasize and point out is
the one underneath the top right bar
where it says important gene documents
so here is a readme a change log and
structural information
files i encourage everybody to read
because these
files contain very important
information for the gene for the website
how we list things what standards we use
and also give you examples of the
features of this
gene page so in fact a lot of
questions i receive i can answer by oh
this is all um
detailed and explained in that readme
file
so i really encourage everybody to check
out um
these files so especially for a cytogram
p450 2d6 which
has a high level of structural variation
we have summarized
a lot of that information in the
structural variation document
which might be very helpful for your
work
then we have a number of features so you
can choose
different reference sequences um to have
the variance and mapped to genomic
transcript
reference sequences but also both genome
builds and in the case for sip 286
also a legacy sequence you can also
choose different count modes have them
mapped to the atg being plus one
which is very helpful just to toggle
between these count modes
uh you can also create custom views uh
using filter options
um and what we also offer
are the cpic clinical
allele function assignments as issued
by on this group and we have
introduced core allele definitions which
are essentially
is a rule-based system to collapse
all sub-alleles we are cataloging into
a major allele definition um if you will
and finally we also assign haplotype
evidence levels
so this really gives you a feel for how
much evidence there is to support a
given haplotype
and this is not to be confused with
evidence
for function but really a quality
um information um
information to uh tell you whether a
hyper type
indeed exists or may not exist
in the form and we are posting it here
i want to quickly um give you um
an overview of our comparative allele
viewer or cave tool
so this is a pretty nifty tool where you
can
choose the alleles you would like to
compare on a selection path which is
shown on the left and then on the right
it shows you a graphical comparison of
these different allelic variants
and so you can see all these blue
squares uh the little pill
sign the farm bar logo
these indicate uh snips that are unique
to an allele
so this example there are two slips
highlighted by this um
by this logo star for a star for snip
and a snip you can find
in the star 100 and so if you find
these snips you have one or the other
allele undefined but you can also see
in the top row for the snip that says
100 ct
that this particular snip can occur
on numerous different variants and so if
you see
this particular snip you cannot really
tell whether you have a star 10 36
49 and so on and so you need to do
additional testing in order to really
drill it down to which
allelic variant you have so seeing um
which snips occur on which allele in a
graphical form
is very helpful um in addition to have
everything
just um tabulated
so as i already mentioned before we have
now also
genes that are not cytogram p450 genes
so you see here not 15 which we have
launched a little bit
more or almost uh two years ago now
dpyd we have launched earlier this year
and soco 1v1 will
start a work in uh in
in this year describe what we do how we
do it
what kind of features we have built and
how we interact with other landscapes
but we also have had uh so far two
papers what we call gene focused papers
in a series we are building
there was the first one was on cytogram
p42d6
the more recent one was on 2c19
and we are working on one for two b6
right now
and these gene of focus papers
give you really a comprehensive overview
of
the variation of these genes uh what
farmvar
is doing and everything you need to know
about
these genes i also want to highlight
that
we are offering templates for authors um
to use to describe genotyping methods
report alleles and diplotype frequencies
and we have devised these tables because
it is sometimes
really really difficult for example
see pic authors or form gkb curators
to tease out that information from
publications
and so we encourage everybody to use
these templates
to be a really clear cut on what was
tested how was the genotype translated
and so on so that would be uh really
helpful
so how do we fit into uh with
other resources and who are we
collaborating with
so first of all uh clinical
pharmacogenetic test reports
often rely on the star allele
nomenclature
so if a test record uses that
nomenclature of course
of them real definitions oh i'm helping
and working with the amp
which is um devising
recommendations for clinical testing
we're also working with a group that is
called the get
rm or the genetic testing reference
materials
group because it is of course um
very helpful to have reference samples
for your testing in the clinical arena
but of course
also in research then we are working
very closely with the form gkb
because it is absolutely important that
we use these allele definitions in a
standard
in a standardized way across all these
different resources
so there is absolutely no questions
about
what does this allele mean or that
allele mean
so a standardized usage of these
terms and the little definitions is key
and then of course the
nomenclature is also used by
bioinformatics tools
to develop algorithms that can call
these star alleles
from testing materials and all this
together
is of course instrumental
to eventually inform
cp guidelines and as you will see they
are using
from bar allele definitions if existing
um to inform the guidelines and the
translation into
um so
for the pharm tkb this is probably
the best known um database for
pharmacogenetics
knowledge and so you find information
for annotated drugs curated pathways
clinical guideline annotations drug
label annotations
but i really want to highlight at the
bottom of the slide in the middle you
see
gene specific information tables this is
a plethora of
information how to translate for example
a diplo type into a phenotype so if you
are not familiar with these
reference tables please go and check
them out
and then of course the pharm tkb is also
known for there are wonderful pathways
they
are putting together
the clinical pharmacogenetics
implementation
consortium is now 11 years old
they have identified that it is
really a barrier to the implementation
of pharmacogenetics
of how to interpret what is a physician
to
do with a genotype when it is available
and to really address this barrier
the cpic was formed to
provide guidelines that enable the
translation of genetic laboratory tests
into actionable prescribing decisions
and so it is important to understand
that the cpic does not recommend weather
testing
should be done but it is designed to
help clinicians understand
how an available genetic test result can
be used to optimize
a drug therapy
so what you see here is a table one
um from sap guideline
and um all these tables one are
very similar in all these guidelines and
so you see uh the phenotype definitions
like
ultrarapid normal or intermediate
metabolizer
for cytochrome p450 2d6 that is the
activity score system that is used to
facilitate the translation of genotype
into a phenotype
there is a brief description of the
genome type
and then to your right you see examples
of
c26 diplotypes and again you see here
the star nomenclature
and these go back to these definitions
that are listed in foam bar so
we are working very closely with the
cpeg
again to standardize the um
usage of these star alleles very
consistently
among the sea peak farm gkb and bonbar
and this is also a reason why we have a
fairly high standards before we define
an allelic variant
to make sure that it is the best
possible definition
because we know that c peak might
eventually
pick up an allelic variant and is basing
our
clinical recommendations on an allele
then clinical test reports use star
nomenclature
so these two examples are very
generic examples reports you might see
and tests might report
star alleles in a table form or as you
can see here
on the right side also list the genotype
and then give you a little range of
where the phenotype might be
and so again it is very important that
unified nomenclature is used for these
test reports
because otherwise it is really
impossible
to interpret these especially across
providers as
patients might leave one institution or
switch
physicians so there is definitely still
a lot of work to do
to make that more unified and
standardized
then of course there are so many
different clinical labs out there
and everybody is doing testing slightly
different
by method or what they test for
and so the association of molecular
pathology has started
to come up with clinical genotype allele
selection
recommendations they are using a
two-tiered system
so tier one is a minimum panel of
alleles that should be
tested tier two is an extended panel of
um
variants and their selections for these
tiers is really based on how frequent
these are
whether an allele occurs in just one or
more populations
whether they are testing materials
available
and so on and so forth and they also use
of course our font var allele
definitions if they are available
and so for
cytogram p450 2c19
they have already published
recommendations and they also have
published recommendations for
2c9 and recommendations are underway
for cytogram p450 and 2d6
moving on to the get rm project
so this is housed at the cdc
and is tasked to develop reference
materials for pcx testing
this is needless to say very important
for clinical laboratories
but of course having good reference
materials is also
important for anything going on in
our research so they collaborate with
the coriol
repositories because these dnas
are widely available and
these groups these groups enlist
commercial and academic laboratories to
perform a pcx uh
testing each sample is tested by
multiple platforms by different
groups to come then up with a consensus
um genotype and they had two um
landmark papers before and then a third
paper was
uh published last fall on soup 2d6
where um 42 new samples
have been added to the list many of
those
containing rare alleles and unusual
genotypes
and this is what you can see here in
table four
and the highlight also is that these
consensus genotypes
are reported out as a star nomenclature
so again emphasizing that you do need
a resource that keeps track of all these
star alleles and sub-alleles and so on
and so forth
because um all these different projects
and groups
rely on it
then there is also tool and algorithm
developments
to interpret genotype data so there are
a number of commercial platforms which
also provide calling tools for these
star alleles
and then there are also independent
academically
developed tools to interpret for example
next generation
sequencing data like australia stargazer
only
uh to name just um these three
and to your left you see uh roughly how
that works
so um in that red box is the allele
definition so these are tables
that go into these algorithms and then
you have your um
genotype data in different formats and
then the algorithm is doing its thing
and is reporting out these diplotypes
based on the allele definitions
that it received as an input and so you
don't need to be a bioinformatician
to understand that the better and
more high quality data the little
definitions are
the better are these interpreted um
diplo types and algorithms
itself so again uh
the more allele variants we are able to
define and the more granularly we can
define them
the better will these tools uh work to
call these
data and uh provides reliable
um diplo type calls
and then here on the last slide i want
to briefly introduce
the farm cat initiative so the farm
gkb together with cpic realized that it
would really
be terrific to have one pipeline
that uses a genotype data which is fed
uh into the algorithm then use the
farmvar allele definitions see
pig clinical recommendations so that a
final report
takes everything together so that you
have one
pathway in one pipeline from the
genotype or sequence data
to a final report for a patient
and so i hope i gave you um
some insights of how complex it is to
really
make precision medicine work so
we are all really in this together and
although i put
farm bar here in the middle piece there
are so many puzzle pieces
that have to come together whether it's
basic research
medical research um education
the pharmacy kb pharmcat ptx testing
physicians to make
this happen for the individualized
for the patient to receive an
individualized a drug prescribing
and move this precision medicine
forward and with this i would like to
thank you for your attention
and i'm happy to take any questions